the man just want to cover tracks
they don't want the problem yeah
they don't want the front
willing to watch a woman burn to her
death rather than own up
mandela amanda my son else
back in the day
mandela starting for social media media
when the deniability clause was was
valid
bro
burn her
burn her is either her roman is got to
be here
[Music]
the guy from tiktok on a pod they were
on this uh pod called it's called the
fellas yeah i see it on the they're
always near us in the chat so i just see
how i see them
who does them i see it but i don't know
because i always
conf when i see the fellas i always
think it's the filthy
it's not the same yeah yeah yeah
these two youtuber guys i can't remember
i know they're boys with the sidemen but
i can't remember their names and i can't
remember anything i felt bad because i
don't remember anything about them but
um yeah they're
they get wankered
on their thing what do you mean like
obviously we take a shot okay okay
is it drink oh gang we're just gang
we're so also
now yeah because imagine i can't imagine
like i don't mind doing the two like two
shots that we do whatever and it's like
all nice and then i'm done but it's only
been a few more we've been like less
drinking yeah yeah yeah yeah i couldn't
do that every single time i couldn't no
no way no no no no no no no no way um
i'm feeling a bit loose already you know
yeah both two shots licks me yeah that's
cause i never drink same ever which i
like same um but anyway guys
what you man saying happy monday happy
monday and that as you can see i've just
escaped penitentiary to be with you man
today
um so don't say i don't and don't say i
don't care all right mine's been an
asylum
um this is so comfortable though i found
it looks it i'm not gonna lie it looks i
said to you when you walked in
h m bro sweat i was gonna say something
like h m tk max he looks it don't say tk
max though
don't say tk max um h m
just to clarify h m um cheap as well
i mean your boy can flex when he wants
to flex or psg's
um but fam this is like 10r and these
are like 15. oh wow cheap bro i was
gonna buy like if they had my size um
because your boys have brought that
extra large now
um
if they had my side would have bought
like five of them fair enough but yeah
so comfortable i never i never go to h m
bar
new year's eve when you all came up
the [ __ ] you got the shirt the shirt i
bought the shirt is from new york
yeah buff shirt as soon as i saw you
as soon as i saw you when i was thinking
he looks good man
he looks good like obviously i'm happy
for you but also i'm just like
what am i doing
i don't see you what am i doing
you're a penguin yeah it's just annoying
i love seeing my boys look lavish and
feel lavish as soon as i saw you i saw
you from across the way and i was just
like
looks great
[Laughter]
he looks great
it's like so casual with it as well it
looked like you put zero effort in
and it's just like you look [ __ ]
fantastic and what what the i don't even
remember what i was wearing
i don't even remember stop it
i'm sure fam
i'm sure you were you were a shirt as
well i'm sure it was like a navy
greenish as well i'm sure it was a green
what it was bro there's a green shirt
you're obviously jeans and oh my god it
was a khaki green shirt yeah yeah a
casual kind of casual yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was all right but now you look
decent bro you look decent you had the
[ __ ]
button down
check shirt black t-shirt gold chain am
i not wrong
with your complexion bro you can't fault
that
you literally can't
don't sweet without that it's [ __ ]
annoying
being light skinned is so difficult
it has bad advantages though but here's
what is yeah
like yeah
you like it's uh
it's annoying bro like i can't pull off
so much being like skinned there's only
you can't work certain things unless you
want to look like [ __ ] justice millet
do you know what i mean
i've heard that name in years wow the
set of colors you're just not allowed to
have but i don't agree with that bro i
don't agree with chris brown his lights
can he wears every single color under
the sun yeah but it's different bro
chris brown wears every color on the sun
in a casual fashion
as a light skin guy you can wear it if i
want to wear this
i can wear this in bright pink right
yellow whatever i don't know gay i just
wear a track suit yeah but if i get a
silk shirt yeah with a gold pattern on
it yeah jesse smaller
that's just the end of it yeah that's
all there is to be said oh jessie
[ __ ] smallett all right um
here's what it is and the same for chris
brown can you imagine chris brown i'm
wearing a silk shirt with a gold trim i
can fitted i can jossy
but then again it's also it's also chris
brown because drake wears that [ __ ] all
the time he's drake
jeremy
i'm not that
but it's always that's hilarious i know
my lane and i stick to it sometimes but
yeah you look back on that to be fair i
could have pulled off what you were
wearing and that's what probably
infuriated me more
that's probably what infuriated me even
more
don't sweep me like that could have been
me don't sweep me like that that's
hilarious but yeah yeah
thank you we all look good man yeah
everyone looked very good good jacob's
moving into more of like a
classic he is he likes his leftovers he
he does
he [ __ ] does it suits it it does it
does to you it's jay yeah yeah yeah yeah
aaron likes to keep it classy
he does he does that's why i was like
you look good brother
you're good today i don't remember what
he's wearing but i remember he wanted a
tea a fitted tee and all the blazer and
jeans and crepes yes he did he likes to
keep it classy always
um
toves will surprise you on the night i
know nobody's going to surprise you on
the night
terms will come into the room with one
outfit and before we leave he's got
another shirt on and then a jacket and
then a hat and he's like damn [ __ ]
you know
he irons and then just falls into glass
and falls into it it's just like yeah
everything's oversized but it looks
amazing it does looks amazing draped on
it
it just drapes on him and you're just
like oh he's got the freshest kicks on
yeah it does ah
i just don't have that it's what i'm
saying do this you see how we're talking
about everyone else and we can guess
what they're gonna wear we don't know
what i'm gonna wear
and frankly no one even gives a [ __ ]
because it's not gonna leave an
impression
whatever stop it james this is whatever
stop it software is bro stop it stop it
stop it stop it that's hilarious and the
excuses are oh yeah but you're light
skinned that's what ever oh [ __ ] that's
what everyone always says yeah but your
light's good
your mom's like
[Music]
this is why we don't need to clean shots
anymore
um
oh a jaw
what's it guys happy monday
happy to have you obviously you're
already caught up on what we spoke about
on thursday um
and if you're not
you've said it before you're a [ __ ]
that's not what you were going that's
not what i thought you were going to say
if you're not
pause the video scoring on over to
shits and patreon.com and catch up guys
every thursday um i get a lot of
messages saying oh if i sign up to
patreon am i just going to get every
episode that comes out or am i going to
get the whole catalog that you've ever
done bro you're going to get the whole
thing the whole thing um so jump on
there binge catch up and then chat with
us we'll do a lot of series
recommendations on there like oh
recommendations on there we talk a lot
about our personal lives on there
and we have a lot of fun as always um
we've got picky poison which is the
patented patreon game 100 uh which we
[ __ ] with every week and uh yeah man
it's a good time and then obviously we
have a monthly zoom chat which is coming
up
next
next week next week next week yeah next
week next few days next week um
which is always a good time we get to
know you guys we get to [ __ ] with you
guys a little bit so patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs sign up today yeah
mom um three part of the month of 10
years free panda mart tempe a day run up
here you know the drill before we get
into the fun fact i need to ask you a
question
have you seen the new slash latest
episode
of demon slayer
no
i was gonna watch it last night but i
didn't i watched it on the train down
here
i'm assuming
uzui is
his buck them
has he has course he has
but he he took that man with him as well
when is zanetsu and uh inusuke
yeah i already know i can't say stuff
because i don't want to spoil yourself
obviously you know yeah yeah yeah i
don't want to say stuff but obviously
you've seen the previous week's episode
so the previous the eyes the red eyes
fam
last week's episode was
i've saw it twice did you i watched it
again i'd watched that twice it was
incredible bro it was [ __ ] sick it
was incredible he's embraced this fire
dance he has he has he's embraced it and
man said
this water thing ain't working for me
let me just do what i'm used to
i waited for that he's just like i'm
sick of this it's just not working for
him
and the man holds his breath and just
does his
is actually top two i was banging
actually top two
this season is
is the most like
i don't think i've been so engulfed in a
season every episode so far
in so long if that makes sense yes fam
it's amazing i was talking to a friend
of mine recently
and she's dating a guy or whatever
and she recommended
jump on demonstrate to him
and then i think however many months
weeks months has been
um she must have hit him up like big man
are you up to date yeah yeah and he said
ah to be fair i watched the first few
episodes couldn't get to it
what kind of crackhead are you scum what
kind of crackheads bearing in mind the
first episode in the first five minutes
you see a loving doting older brother
with a cute little family who then
his whole family gets murdered and
destroyed
his sister becomes a demon who tries to
kill him
a lot happens and he meets a hashera in
the first episode bro one of the most
top 10 most powerful characters in the
whole show he means so in the first
episode you meet
you see what demon is his you see his
whole family blooded guts dead his
sisters are [ __ ] demon and you meet
hasher in the first episode master i
can't get into it
what do you what do you want what more
do you want from an anime what do you
want from life yeah what excites you
he's a waste man whatever he is whoever
because i don't understand i'm trying to
get bella to watch it because she
watched
not last week's episode the week before
where zanetsu did the thunderclap thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah
when he sleeps and he just pans into
vision i'm thinking you're about to go
demon time and he like you said he's
literally the underrated go of the
series oh
man has done two or three moves in 27
episodes and they've been so clutch bro
so in the movie clutch where my girl
what's the [ __ ] what's the sister's
name again
uh
who's that um
nezuko nezuko yeah when nezuko was in
the in the cart he's struggling with
that yeah yeah yeah and then you just
hear that thunder clap
and man just chops the whole thing
he loves her a sleep fam just hey oh oh
bro he just bends over that one he's
only got that one
yeah yeah
he's gone he is the underrated goat of
the anime
but wait the way tengen comes into play
in this episode yeah wow okay i'm in
touch
[Laughter]
but there's a twist
if
you take guys if you take anything away
from today's episode it's watch demon
slayer the first seasons on netflix
the movies on crunchyroll and the second
seasons on crunchyroll please a twist
please bro
bros and bro bro whatever you want to
call it rose and bras please watch it
yeah yeah because there's a twist in the
next episode [ __ ] all right say let's
watch it tonight
juicy i want you to like stop please
i might watch it again on the way back
home say less this is better than last
week's with the red eyes
more fam
last week's episode and a week before
that as well they were both as good but
i think because of the climax of this
episode i already know next week is pop
in say list
next week is poppin they love a
cliffhanger in that show and it's the
cliffhangers get better and better and
better because i already know next week
is arms house from
random
girls wanna [ __ ] tengen
yes they do girls one off tenkin's a man
okay tengen's a man man tengenza his
shoulders don't make sense the
vascularity in his shoulders don't make
sense in that episode where he saved
them from the kit in the cave blob like
three episodes ago and he just walked
towards them and they were crying the
height difference do you know many times
on tick tock i've seen people say the
height the height difference then just
pats them on the head and the head
he just looks back at them with his
shoulders like that
it looks like they filmed lord of the
rings on his shoulders
jeremy
the mountains of mordor were shot on my
man's delts bro
that's the funniest thing you said today
i'm sweating
bro
oh my god the vertical peaks
of mithandril were shot on my man's
anterior delt it doesn't make sense
so wham he's too wham but do you know
the actual craziest thing about that
he's the weakest ashira is he he's the
weakest
by his own admission
oh no i googled it you googled it yeah
wow he's the weakest i think there was
like nine or ten of them he's the
weakest
wow and i couldn't believe it when i saw
it he's arms bro
he chopped that thing for fun family
there's what he he came into action this
episode right and you know he's very
flashy yeah yeah he loves the flashlight
he loves the
the way he came into focus and came into
shot in this episode
wow bro obviously daddy's fast movement
thing and he was talking talking talking
still holding these knives
i can't possibly give me a fun fact i
don't want to do this anymore give me a
fun fact and let's move on bro because
i'm getting excited i just don't want to
spoil it because i'll ask you everything
all right
guys we're just going to share some love
on our boys over at man's
so guys
obviously it's the new year it's a new
you okay it's time to freshen up down
there in the new year we need the crop
preserver okay so manscape have got you
covered with the crop preserver it's an
anti-chafing ball deodorant and
moisturizer okay ball duration and
moisturizer i i'm sure
barely any of you moisturize your ball
let alone deodorize them
you already put deodorant on your armpit
so why are you neglecting the smelliest
[ __ ] part of your body there you go i
don't know you i'm only just realizing
why you don't and obviously you're gonna
go over and you're gonna purchase the
thing okay so for on the go freshness um
after you leave the gym you'll leave
you'll love the uh crop provider
ball toner spray as well guys okay so if
you want to get involved get yourself
some crop reviver spray you're going to
get yourself some deodorant some toner
um you're going to get some anti-chafe
boxers my guy best boxes in the business
bro you want to go to mansgape.com grab
yourself a little perfect package 4.0
it's going to give you everything and
more
and you're going to use the code sng the
sierra november golf manscape.com
code is sng that's going to give you 20
off free shipping worldwide feel good
stay fresh anti-chafe
clapping cheeks skin no pubes 20 22 is
there is baby face
baby face balls baby face balls that's
baby's face that's the hashtag whatever
22 yeah yeah so um before
anything else let's let's get back to
the episode guys thank you very much
okay cool this one i said to you before
this fun fact is very interesting
um this fun fact is pornhub's most
viewed categories in the world
i'm so happy you've done this i've seen
someone i'd burn in my i don't wanna i i
can't spoil it because i don't remember
what they were okay but twenty because
they do it every year yes twenty i've
seen the twenty twenty one on another
pod that i listened to right what is it
and they did it and i was like
fascinating gang so this is the 2021
year review up so last year's um
categories of pornhub
well across the world countries across
the uh country slash continents more
continental continents yeah okay so okay
cool can i guess of course you can see
so it's the top search term is it yes
top categories yes
category okay um so we've got asia yeah
yeah
but it's the thing is it's because
obviously asia's massive so it's got
like southeast asia split into different
segments in asia okay give me a segment
and i'll try and guess what their
thing is
like
it doesn't say what segment it is so
like the main bit of asia like the
biggest bit so where china is china and
dead man is japan in there as well japan
is underneath it doesn't say the
country's names it just
has the colors and what the category is
it doesn't shine
i'm gonna say
that part of asia has got to be like
hentai it is is it
it's gotta be so stereotypical it's
gotta be hentai it is head time bro okay
all right let me let me go through them
so
north america the most popular search is
lesbian porn really yes bro interesting
no i said north america sorry
i'm pretty sure it's canada canada sorry
lesbian porn
america like united states of america
ebony porn
most part of south america oh let me
anal no
brother not even a speck of anal in the
grand scheme
um
okay
that surprises me because most south
americans love a bit of background if
you type in brazil
that's all
that's all they know
would i use the vagina for us to piss
nothing more nothing less all right um
south america
is gonna be
uh
it's a toss between two there's it's
like a 60 40 split
i'm gonna say
is it is any of them controversial
uh
not really okay not really uh i'm gonna
say oh well it depends on how you look
at it yeah
um i'm i'm gonna say
[ __ ] south america yeah bro what
south america
i don't know like
bbl
no that's not even like that's not even
the
top eight categories all right go on
something what are the two one of the
two splits so the two majority splits
the majority is hentai
really bro for south america south
america this i'm not making freaking all
right and the other part is lesbian
really again yeah bro
and this is never searched lesbian in my
life there's a small speck so it's like
60 percent
uh
i would say 35 percent lesbian and five
percent ebony ebony yeah in south
america all three of those surprised me
yep i was thinking ain't no annoying
anal angel
that's what i would think
that's all they know
that's their expertise
that's where they really come into their
own because if you're looking for a
little anal
you it's something colombian brazilian
yeah yeah yeah yeah argentina yeah it's
satin fam it's oil there's there's
there's oil on the skin black yeah and
there's cheeks there's brown skin and
there's oil fam always always in south
america always broadcast i'm surprised
it's not a search term fam
um australia
has it i guess
australia
um
i don't know like
milf no but that is a category but no
it's a lesbian as well
what's going on with that
i don't know
let's never searched it i've never
searched for less obviously it's popped
up in like categories but i've never
searched for lesbian porn for me bro
yeah lesbian i need to feel like i'm
there
yeah exactly
um africa
oh
it's split into i'd say 75 percent one
and then there's like two others that
dotted about there's one you would never
get uh interracial
that's not even a category on here
really i'm just crazy to me
which is crazy i don't think you
understand how crazy that is to me
that's your go-to that's family
that's your bread and butt
interracial is not even in their top
eight categories of 2021.
it doesn't make sense to me
i wake up and think obviously
interracial
where else could it be
you know
you can tell we've had shots
you can tell we've had shots oh god
that's hilarious
um
uh africa yeah um
think of some categories um
there's one that's bait
and then there's
okay ebony that's the biggest one that's
probably around seven seven i'd say
seventy percent of the continent right
cool
um and they've got another one and then
you've got
another
three i'd say
ten percent
how much did i say ebony was like 70 i
say ebony's 80 then you've got another
10 and 25
pog
that's not even a caggy um guys i don't
know what porg is is pretty ass white
girl
i don't know tell me film
so
one is lesbian
which makes no no no no no
no say it i lied yes what is lesbian i'm
just gonna start saying that when you
ask me to guess i'm just gonna start one
is lesbian a small
minority is anal
and then there's one that threw me yeah
go on arab
in africa and north africa north yeah of
course north africa like egypt and then
west west not east africa as well oh
okay this africa surprises me north
africa does not surprise me at all
that's egypt then places there morocco
yeah they're gonna be searching that
yeah they're gonna be searching that
fair enough they're muslim countries
fair enough yeah yeah
all right the rest of asia you've got a
hentai which is obviously the major pit
japan is obviously japanese porn in
india is obviously indian porn a huge
part of like the
united arab emirates all that psycho
weight them size anal really anal
that's all they want interesting anal
with like a splash of japanese but it's
all anal
interesting in europe the in europe
there's milk 100 milf in europe hundreds
i'm not even gonna let you say it i know
it's there i know it's three milf is one
of them
there's milf
there's anal and there's a lesbian this
lesbian thing is perplexed family i need
cleaning needs to watch lesbian porn
clearly i need to watch we're missing
we're missing something huge apparently
oh that's funny but yeah those are the
so the eight categories are
japanese lesbian ebony hentai milf milf
milf
anal indian arab
fair play
the fact that interracial is not even in
there
blows my mind
i didn't even get it
fair enough i don't think you get
but i
thing is i do get because that's not
what i search for so i do get this not
in there i've never searched for it but
i know for a fact that's all you search
for
so it's hilarious to me how infuriated
and perplexed you are i'm not infuriated
i've been playing i'm far from
infuriated i'm just replacing do you
think that's that's what that's what
porn is made yeah that's what man up are
producing
because you're thinking there's so much
content that's going to waste here
because they're clearly that's all
they're making videos for because every
time i go on the thing that's what's
available to me
that's my suggested that's that's what
i'm searching for yeah
that's too funny bro oh i saw that i was
thinking wow that's a that's a great fun
fact
that's a great fun fact it is
all right but yeah you said you had a
trash news right yes i do it's an actual
it's actually a video um
it's on twitter
so
there is
a there is a guy that actually sleeps
with a family of cheaters
actual cheaters i'm gonna read the
marina
a family a family of cheese asleep with
a forest guard every night the forest
department wanted wanted to investigate
this
once investigate this claim by
installing a cctv camera this is what
the camera recorded not sure if the
storyline is true but the bonding is
genuine and amazing i'm going to show
you the whole thing
it's it's
it looks like he he wakes up and he
doesn't know where he is
and it's like the whole family of
cheetah are there oh my god family and
he cuddles
all of them
he must have raised them or some [ __ ]
100 percent he raised them there's no
other way [ __ ] huge they're humongous
oh my god
thing is i've never seen anything like
that yeah me neither some people are
crazy bro
one thing is i i'm not under any
illusion i don't think
i could right i i can accept this more
than a family of lions yeah
because lions are [ __ ] huge yeah
cheetahs are massive
but i'm
75 certain if i connected i could rock a
cheater
you think
based on the size of their skull
i reckon if it was darting at me
that's why i said if i connected i
reckon if i if there's one on one yeah
and a a cheat was genuinely sending for
me yeah if it jumped up and i just
rocked it right
under its jaw here on the right hand
side yeah i reckon i could knock it out
you think just one okay because that
would be my like that's it yeah my
united states of smash
like my obliques were in it everything
went up
and then
everything's done i'll probably crack my
hand on his jawline but then he's going
to be finished he's going to slide to
the side if there's another one there
dead
take me
because i've got nothing left but i
reckon just a cheetah yeah 101
smack i reckon i do reckon i could take
it wow fair enough i don't fancy my
chances massively yeah but if i connect
i'm 75 certain he's done
so i said if i connect clean he's done
he's done obviously a lion on the other
hand
it will have me up yeah my hand as i'm
trying to do something
and it will hold the bang as well hold
the bag hold the bang it'll just piss
him off more
you're just resisting the rest
let me have you bro yeah yeah yeah yeah
stop resisting oh my god yeah a line of
them think they're a tiger not none of
them i would have i wouldn't be able to
manage any of them a cheater one of them
when i reckon i could [ __ ] thump his
lights out
fair enough bro that's if
if you connect oh if i can except fast i
know that so my timing needs to be elite
at least an understatement yeah yeah
yeah
it needs to be [ __ ] but imagine the
rush
i feel like you're back here
rush
a cheater a grown cheater cinder for me
and i give him that
kid
and he skids to the side and all the
surrogate dust just goes you see his
legs before
and then he tries to get up and goes
i'll scream
i'll drop to my knees and scream rip my
top off
i can see it now someone suck me off
immediately bro because i'm such a man
bro that would be amazing no one would
ever believe that story no no one would
believe that story no one would ever
believe that in a million years but yeah
i reckon that could happen
um
speaking of
randomly quickly to bring it back to um
demonstrate for a second yes
cosplay this year is going to be all
about that demon
all about she's barf yeah yeah
she's going to be
what um i think it was three four years
ago suicide squad what's her favorite
harley quinn yeah be her everyone's
gonna be her cosplay yeah yeah yeah what
is her name she's the um sick upper
sixth ranked person i don't know my name
i don't know her name papa sick that
[ __ ]
i didn't even geisha yet yeah she yeah
she is with them
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm done
i'm done bro
[Laughter]
it's mad
i was on the trays and my my pupil
dilated brother i couldn't believe what
i'm seeing
oh it's it's nuts it's nuts cool
you know what i have to do um
actually
this is oh before i've got something i
wanted to say but this randomly just
sprung to my head you know for the last
few weeks we've been doing some uh
creator appreciation yes of course right
i want to give some creative
appreciation to this one don okay this
is very
well i guess all of it's unexpected what
we do but this one
so
do you watch um afterlife on netflix no
but i've heard it's really good it is
[ __ ] good ricky gervais
raises a beast right of course so
there's a guy on tick tock you may have
seen him we may not his name's cole
anderson okay light-skinned brother i
might not know by name but if i see his
face maybe you probably have okay um
light skin bro
um
probably looks a bit younger than us
maybe our age i'm not sure um
funny bro he just does comedy skits
funny brother and i remember the first
time i saw him
he must he probably had like three maybe
four hundred thousand followers okay on
tick tock okay and i remember saying to
myself this guy gives me mad ricky
gervais vibes
like david brent the office vibes okay
just the awkward comedy of it i was like
i remember thinking this guy must love
ricky gervais because like he he does it
very [ __ ] well but he gives me mad
ricky gervais vibes just the way his
comedy is and he's really really good um
and
i heard an interview of his recently
ricky or this brother this brother okay
and
um
he is on season three of afterlife
mm-hmm just a quick cameo ticket just a
quick little little scene in there funny
i watched it the other day because as
soon as i heard that he was on it he
said on the interview what episode he's
done i was like
take me to that episode yeah i want to
see him one day and he's itching on it
for 60 seconds smashes it but the cool
thing about my man is what he said was
is that he was doing all this tick tock
stuff he's a big fan of ricky gervais
which i i guess anyway
um and he used to do
lip sync stuff from like scenes from the
office okay the english office okay i've
never seen the english office by the way
never seen it never fantastic i've seen
that's a live i think i've seen maybe
one or two episodes max
max but i've always said sorry to cut
you off as well by the way but i've
always heard that the us one is funnier
than a uk ones have always just people
self-interview this one okay the thing
is with me just to digress for a little
bit people always say they think the us
is funnier than the uk
but
first of all i grew up in the uk so i'm
going to be a bit biased but
the you the way the us office does its
comedy is so
obvious there's no nuance to the comedy
do you know i mean you don't like
it's like
how do i explain it there's a scene so
if you know um this is random you know
the karate kid movie with um
jen smith yes
there's a bit in there where you know
the thing that he's chatting to i saw
this i don't remember okay anyway he
fancies this girl okay she's a violinist
okay and then
the
she's trying to get a timing down and
she's trying to get everything and her
instructor always says you need to play
the pauses
so
when you're doing a pause you're not
waiting for the next bit you're
accentuating the pause the pause is part
of the song okay and you need to play
that pause okay utilize the pause all
right it's not just silence for the sake
of silence okay it's part of the music
okay
and that's what i feel the difference is
between the uk office and a lot of uk
comedy and the us office okay the u.s
don't play the pauses
the pauses are just a break to get to
the next bit with the uk use the pause
bro okay use the awkwardness i'm
assuming you've seen all of the uk
obviously in all of the uk all the us
fair enough i've not seen the uk one
side
i've seen all the uk like five times oh
really so it's only like two or three
seasons there's like two seasons bro to
me it's top five one of the funniest
things i need to watch it then and it's
just the awkwardness they use the the
silence is the comedy in the uk one it's
the whole like
the violation ricky gervais puts people
through
and there's just the silence that it
imbues
yeah and everyone like did you just
[ __ ] say that to me yeah but because
he's the boss of the thing yeah no one
can call him out yeah he feels the pain
of what he's just said yeah and he has
to sit in it yeah oh it's perfect okay
it's my type of comedy okay anyway um
so this cole anderson brother um
mentioned that he so he used to do lip
syncing from the uk office he put it on
twitter one time and at ricky gervais
and richard liked it on twitter so he
was like gang kept putting him out kept
putting them out and then ricky james
followed him on twitter so he was like
gang so
he dm'd ricky gervais
just typical big fan la da right kids
gave a double tap ting
cool moving on i think we get into like
new year's eve january 2020 probably
mm-hmm and um or maybe 2021 he messages
ricky surveys again like i just want to
wish you happy new today's game with one
of them
now any same human being just would stop
anyone gives me that yeah just you won't
hear from me again i promise you now i
don't care who you are yeah the thumbs
up is very um just leave me alone it's
it's like it's a conversation ender
that's what that is to me when people
send me this i see this
that is literally the finger whichever
thing it does whatever finger it is when
you give me this i see this um
i'm not chatting to you anymore yeah
yeah you don't want me here yeah so he
gave him one of these
and then he was alright man whatever
and he said um
he noticed that they were
releasing a season three of afterlife
okay and he's a massive ricky race fan
he's a massive afterlife fan so he died
ricky gervais almost like look
for the sake of don't ask don't get um
what are the chances of me getting a
young cameo on on afterlife three and
richard rose replied and was like i'll
think about it but then he just never
heard anything again he said a few
months down the line
he saw on instagram and twitter stuff
that they'd already started filming for
it and it was like the breasts or that
the brain
and the crew had already started feeling
it after life three so he was like cool
yeah then a few days after that he gets
an email
like and it just literally said after
like three three auditions
so we had a zoom call with ricky gervais
with like the the production team
everything and apparently they didn't
even have
a part for him they didn't even have a
part he could do they had to write him
into the script oh wow because ricky
favors wanted them in there oh wow so
then he did it bro and that was his
first ever acting gig erinson
that's incredible that's incredible bro
and he's really really really good at
tick tock he's really really good i
really really [ __ ] enjoy his stuff
that's incredible man bro and he's gone
like just under a million followers now
i think and i consistently keep up with
his content because i actually think
he's one of the few people that i think
is genuinely original genuinely funny
okay from the uk yeah send me one of his
ideas i will say about his face but i'll
show his face very quickly now okay this
brother
yes i have seen him
no way yes i have seen this i've never
knew his name yeah i've seen him yeah
cool cool cool cool cool so yeah man um
carl anderson appreciation day cool well
played well played carl
good job bro good [ __ ] played well
played that's that is literally shooting
your shot fan that is literally shooting
your shirt the definition of that's the
definition of shooting your [ __ ]
shark well played and
you got nothing to lose nothing to lose
everything's again well done played well
done played well played cole yeah man he
[ __ ] smashed it yeah i was i was
super happy when i heard that story i
was like
[ __ ] props well played man [ __ ]
props because if you didn't do that
there was no way it was happening yeah
of course not he has no reason to just
invite you to be part of the show at all
and he just banned quick dm
sorted that's on your cv fam that's
really good mum that's really cameo or
not like it's so [ __ ] netflix ricky
gervais ricardo's worldwide brother did
you know the ricky gervais show was on
hbo
really yes brother i didn't know that
ricky gervais show i was watching it
it comes on late on like e4 so i was
watching last night and the night before
i was thinking this was i actually
didn't even
clock at the time when i was like
obviously it's like 2001 it's like it's
old i didn't clock it was a podcast yeah
obviously i know it's a podcast of its
kind exactly but at the time i just
thought it was a show yes that's sort of
an animated show but if it's a [ __ ]
podcast no one knew it was a podcast
because podcasts weren't it wasn't a
thing then i was like you're so ahead of
the curve brother it makes no wonder
you're so great at what you do joe rogan
often says that
ricky gervais is one of the original
podcasters he names a few different
people but joe rogan would say there's
another guy i can't remember but he's
always on joe rogan but he'll always say
ricky gervais is one of the original
podcasters before podcasting was
actually probably
he's a guy i love ricky gervais he's one
of the funniest guys he's stand up to me
is true outrageously yes yes because he
fears nothing and no one he will say any
and everything that's what he says what
can you do to man it's a joke [ __ ]
relax
that's basically he will say that on
live tv yeah [ __ ] relax i love it man
yeah
right he's a [ __ ] guy so i was super
happy to hear that story because i was
like that's my dream yeah i'm gonna
watch after that now because i've seen
it's great i've seen so many records oh
it's really good
it's really the first episode hits you
really i know the premise of it so yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's good it's good
i'll watch it cool um
sharp left turn here we go fam we'll
come back
[Applause]
every time you do this i think we need
like a but
[Applause]
we need one of these for you yeah cool
cool
some sound effects yeah um i was
actually looking into some sound effects
not long ago i didn't talk to you about
it but yeah i've got some i've got
something for us okay um
say less but uh yeah
sharp left turn
so i mentioned to you this before we
went live
post not clarity
yeah
it's not clarity yeah yeah
before
um
pnc was pnc
yeah i was thinking what the [ __ ] is pnc
yes before pnc was pnc yeah do you know
what i think it was what witch hunting
explain hear me out explain to me so you
know like
old witch hunt in like in salem
these old
time like
which aren't like burn them at the stake
which yep yep i'm pretty sure that
literally was my theory is is that that
was pnc okay hit me and no one knew what
it was hit me so picture this right
you're a married man yeah you're happy
in love with your wife
[Music]
you're out with the boys drinking mead
having a good time
you absolutely wasted drinking some
whole wheat mead and you're having the
time of your life
next
titties in your face okay
the bar keep yeah titties
and you don't know what to do yeah yeah
yeah she's chirps in you fat i can
already see you like some gaily comfort
braids yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah next thing you know
you're back at the barn clapping cheeks
bro okay clapping clapping clapping
clapping okay let's give her a name
what's her name the barkeep the barbecue
um let's call her sabrina sabrina
sabrina the teenage witch yeah okay
let's call her sabrina yeah it says
you're clapping sabrina's cheeks
you bus
you your wife catches you
mandem are around you're in public fam
and obviously united now yeah pnc kicks
in of course fam you look at sabrina you
look at your wife you look at the man
then they're all here in shock and you
think
what am i doing here
what am i doing yeah what is going on
yeah yeah yeah i'm in a barn i'm married
i love my wife i love my children the
boys are looking at leather don't know
who i am yeah i don't want to be here
yeah i don't like this i didn't even
know this woman yeah like
i don't want her near me i don't want
her to touch me it's a hat she must have
been witched to me
yeah this whole cast a spell on me yeah
yeah
and amanda be the man and then back it
yeah
they're mad and being nevada they back
it 100 yeah next thing you know she's a
witch yeah she's on the stage she's on
the stake
your wife is consoling you saying i
forgive you is fine i understand like
she is a witch because women aren't for
women we've been saying it kind of been
your man's fault it must have been hers
we established this in like episode
three yeah women are women she's a home
wrecking hoe yeah she's a witch yeah
burn her claw yeah
and so you know the whole town
is back in it and and then
before we know it
donny who lives four doors down he was
clapping sabrina four weeks ago now he's
got justification as well he doesn't
understand yeah so he's telling his
missus big fan i told you bro yeah yeah
i wasn't about it this happened to me
this happened to me too sabrina has been
bewitching all the mandarin she's
wrecking all the homes the wives want
her done because they want their man at
yards yeah the man just want to cover
tracks
they don't want the problem yeah
they don't want the frog
willing to watch a woman burn to her
death rather than own up
mandela amanda my son else
back in the day
mandela
starting all social media when the
deniability clause was was valid
bro
burn her
burn her is either her i mean it's got
to be her it's got to be her because it
can't be me it can't be me got too much
to lose yeah and the mandan will blindly
back you bro the man will blindly back
you and next week you know she's dead
and it happens again and again and again
because the testosterone hits you twice
you're doing it again
now it's a habit
now it now it reaches the pope now it
reaches everyone the pope now the whole
christian religion is behind you yeah
yeah yeah yeah because we all need
deniability yeah yeah the best thing we
can do is come together as a species and
just burn them yeah just say these men
are witches we have to burn the thoughts
are witches and they're putting spells
on man
i'm pretty sure that's what happened yo
that's a that's a great theory i like it
i like it i've pictured it animated and
i want to animate it i love that all
right
hilarious
that's actually hilarious um you got
some twitter tweeting fam i want to show
you a video on twitter first and then
i'll go into the twitter tweets
it's one of the
it's not even in english but you're
gonna understand everything all right
but
michael says
she'd rather abandon her whole meal than
have some someone take a bite
but the choke
what have i done
nah fam
i've helped that before though the choke
thing deaded me
she was about to lose her life for the
food
i'd rather the rats eat this than you
[ __ ] touch it don't you ever put your
hand on my plate
without consent
[ __ ] you
that's where it starts it starts at home
with these girls literally it starts at
home touching man's food
oh my god anyway
i saw that's where i'm thinking yo this
is the funniest place alive
twitter is the crazy funny funniest
place alive randomly twitter is crazy
crazy funny the funniest place to live
bravo right so hang on you're about to
make me laugh in it
we'll see but you go you were going to
say something no i was just going to oh
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i hope so all right
i've got a few i've got like 16. what'd
you say i've got 16 of them
why is that funny unless i've got a few
i've got 16. yeah there's 16 tweets it's
going to take a minute oh [ __ ] it out
all right hang on
because i'm just oh i love it bro but i
swear and i like i get itchy and
everything so go on go on go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go i've
read the i've read the climax of one of
them
i'm laughing already
[ __ ] sake all right go on go go go go
go
you're going to sweat through this all
right
all right go i'm going i'm vexed for
five minutes away all right go
my uber profile says i'm deaf
so when i get into ubers i usually just
sign hello
i usually just sign hello to them and
don't speak and don't speak anymore but
this uber driver just called someone and
said
this deaf [ __ ] just got in so i could
talk for a minute
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh god right d are you not going to
remember this how much do you remember
anything about the first matrix movie
funny enough no it's actually not the
first one it's actually not the first
one which one it's the one i watched all
three of them last year oh
you
okay
there's a bit
where he meets the architect it might be
number three
he means that neo goes and meets the
architects the white room the white guy
with the white beard the white guy with
the yes yes yes yes and there's a bag of
tv yeah yeah one of them
i saw the funniest
the black lady is the oracle isn't it
the black ladies the oracle
i saw
hang on i sent it to my brother
i saw the funniest
flipping
video on tick tock the other day
press play on that thing
and read the caption
okay
[Music]
bro
for the audio listeners right the
caption is girlfriend saying you must be
[ __ ] if you if you think you're
going out drinking again and neo's just
screaming
nia's just screaming screaming he sounds
like a deaf guy trying to talk he does
oh if
i saw that and i was on the floor bro
every time he screams again it compounds
the funniest of course of course because
it actually sounds like a deaf guy
trying to speak
oh it's nuts it's nuts it's nuts people
on tick tock are sick in the head oh my
days tick tock and twitter people on
social media are the general public on
social media are sick in their head to
think that it's the funniest thing
because they can get away with it on
social media yeah it's not real life
it's not real life oh it's too funny
right
so a chick tweeted
gray sweatpants aren't for dudes i'm
sorry gray sweatpants are for dudes with
dick not dudes with pee pees and then a
guy replied to that saying
but if i say leggings are for [ __ ]
with us not with [ __ ] with long backs
i'm the bad guy
that's so true bam long backs syndrome
truth
backs baby
[Music]
no it actually is though it is
it is
it is
it's painful it is is and
it just literally is what it is there's
nothing else we can say about it i can't
dive into it i just can't let's not yeah
because it yeah it's just gonna pun
intended and not pun intended i can't i
can't drive into it i just can't i said
it or not i can't dive into it i'm sorry
i'm sorry
yeah that's funny bro it's gonna cause a
hurricane of stress we don't need it it
will but let's yeah yeah
sorry go on
why mcdonald's want to call their sprite
a soft drink [ __ ] that's hard liquor
a cold sprite from mcdonald's the
fizziest thing on this earth it will
burn your esophagus it's the fizziest
thing on this planet i would never drink
a sprite bro sprite and dr pepper don't
make sense how fizzy they are oh
i don't care how sad i am
i must still put on some r b to make the
situation worse
that's toby oh toby on a midnight drive
oh my god it is bro it is he wants to
pull up in the hard shoulder and cry
rnab makes situation so much worse but
so much better for the soul of course
it's like it's a mix and match of both
emotions bro and it hits worse when the
lyrics actually coincide with what
you're going through you force them to
go inside with it
you force them to
it's it's like [ __ ] he actually wrote
this for me or she wrote this lyrics for
me literally
literally
one used to smack me up
usher you got it bad
rhythm bro rhythm i had no
situation in my life there was anything
like that
but it's just like
why don't she want me bruv
why won't she take me
there was no she i just wanted to do it
i just wanted to be loved oh that's
hilarious this one spoke volumes to me
you don't realize how valuable breathing
is until you're until you have a blocked
nose
that is me when you're trying to sleep
when you have to breathe for your mouth
when you're trying to sleep sam you
might as well shoot up a skull that's
how i feel jeremy
it's so infuriating
it's so infuriating and that's the only
way you can lay out yeah
every night and vexed every night and
vex you should see someone about that
fan what do you mean every time
about said every night and vex every
night no wonder you're tired i'm vexed
every night brother what do you mean you
got bloodless every night every night
that's sinusitis my g
get fixed you've got tumors in your
nostrils
you need to see someone i'm not joking
stop looking at your phone to move on
i'm not joking
shut up
shut up let me move on [ __ ] i'll deal
with that tonight
that's funny my throat
all right someone tweeted a chick
tweeted
why do men twitch so violently in their
sleep
and a guy replied
the bible says there shall be no rest
for the wicked
[Laughter]
that hurt bro the bible says there shall
be no rest for the
twitch wicked my sleep i sh i [ __ ]
jump out my skin in my sleep i hate it
i hate it
oh god oh it's the funniest thing oh god
[Laughter]
the funniest one i've ever heard that's
the funniest one i've ever heard um the
other one was the baby your [ __ ]
cindy oh yeah
you want us to say [ __ ] cool
that's the second one that's the third
one i'm sweating
i'm sweating oh right
this is actually pretty true this
pandemic just proved y'all would hide
your zombie bites if it came down to it
oh i saw that the other day i actually
saw that the other day hilarious 100
hilarious hundred percent that man would
hide everything to get into dunya yeah
same same same same so would i though
everyone would if i'm amongst strangers
yeah
i have not been bitten fam of course not
because when i change i change yeah
jeremy there's no going back yeah when i
change i change it it's your problem
yeah
you should have realized the signs from
the earth i'm gonna die either
from the change yeah or one of you man
is gonna have me up i'm not gonna have
that yeah yeah yeah
so [ __ ] all of you right bet
up fam
sometimes when people tweet i'm thinking
you guys are geniuses because this is so
true
i consider the second page of google
results the dark web
i don't remember the last time i saw the
second page of google results if i'm
searching for something and it's not on
the first page don't bother me
i'm not clicking page two
do you know what i mean if it's not in
the first three yeah yeah yeah to be
fair i've become savvy to the ads now
because the first three is always
and then it will give you the rules yeah
yeah yeah i i i used to fall for the ads
now i'm just like you you man paid for
this let me get to the real the real the
real [ __ ] but yeah if i'm not clicking
i'm never going on page two
that's one of the realest tweets i've
ever seen yeah that's funny freeless
tweets i've ever seen
me
me twitty go on [ __ ] wake up
and the first thing they do is grab
their phone they don't even know if
their legs work
i saw that one
[Laughter]
fam
to a tv i need to start leaving my phone
in the other room or certainly if i if i
don't need to set an alarm i need to
leave my phone in the room because i'm
tired of waking up and draws from my
phone yeah it's not healthy fast
it's not healthy
i don't know what i'm looking for
and i can't find it every morning i
can't find it i don't know what i'm
looking for and i can't fight it stop it
stop it stop it you sound like you're
searching for answers bro that's lit
yes i'm searching for satin bro
and i can never [ __ ] find it i hate
it and my eyes aren't even barely open
i'm scratching that yeah yeah that's not
normal about my hate because i'm still
defrosted i'm not i'm not reaching out
yeah
no i'm sweating
oh all right next one
i'd rather take my own life before i
shave all my hair off
i'm terrified yeah
yo
dad's be like go help your mother bro go
help your wife
a lie though
a lie though
facts
this one
is
this one is jokes all right gone
made his fingers obviously a girl
tweeted this may his fingers break every
time he likes another girl's picture
girls can't stand you like in a girl's
picture
the funniest thing about that is that
yes man them do but the act of
fingers breaking is so precise bro go
for your jugular when they send for you
fam have you seen there's a thing around
tik tok at the minute
about girls trying to find out if their
man knows who ashcash is have you seen
it no i've not actually bro
girls can't stand the idea of their man
just knowing who ash cash is okay it's
hilarious because have you seen that
there's a obviously they have sounds on
tick tock and stuff yes there's a sound
that's like i always says like that
would be nice have you seen that
maybe bro maybe
i'm not i'm not tick-tock as much as oh
you're not you're not you need to get
back on fire i know it's cancer but you
need to be using cancer is an
understatement
fam
cancer can't say it's understatement i'm
promising
2020 locked down
i would go on tick tock at midnight i
won't sleep till 6am
that's drug abuse that's why i said
cancer is an understatement i wouldn't
sleep brother
i don't think you understand yeah you're
an addict fan to be fair you sh
with that statement alone you should
stay away from i can't do it anymore i
was actually saying to my boy i want to
see my boy the other day i haven't seen
him in a while and his misses i was at
their house and neither of them on tick
tock and obviously these men know your
boys are tick-tock famous
they're fake we're famous
it's a joke but it's not a joke stop it
some guy messaged me the other day yeah
i was like big man i swear i just served
you at the mcdonald's drive-through
so he said
yeah to be fair the bread was staring at
me
eyes wide yeah he had a mask and his
eyes like that and he leaned
forward and then um i didn't think much
of it and then i get home i put my
instagram yeah see a request and it's
like bro
something along the lines of correct me
if i'm wrong yeah but i swear i you i
just served you in the mcdonald's driver
and then
like a [ __ ] i was like slightly
along the lines of
that's funny because
i didn't see
anything in my bag that i didn't pay for
because if i was like i'm a big fan
there was zero apple pies in my bag
so i can't be that you can't be that
much of a fan yeah i paid for everything
that was in there
you didn't even slide me a little
something you slide me anything just
like something i paid full price and
everything that i ordered and paid for
was in the bag nothing more
so you're not a fan you're not a fan
you just acknowledged who i was but
anyway your boys and ticks aren't famous
um
and i went to my boys the other day i
was talking about tick tock and stuff
and he was oh i need to get on tik tok
but i'm on social media so much about as
i am and i was like fam like as much as
everyone should have to talk in their
life
don't do it
don't do it if you're susceptible
to [ __ ] gullible is the word if you're
gullible
it will never let you out fam that was
me when i first got on here it was like
crack to me
i couldn't believe what i was witnessing
on tickets
is social media heroin yeah you can't
get enough you can't and then you you
know
you [ __ ] it
when you're watching a three minute
video of some random guy in mongolia
chopping wood
i think i've seen one of those guys i've
seen one i don't know if it's one good
but i've seen one of them they're just
out here chopping wood or they're
digging in mud for eels or some [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] and you're watching the
whole thing and you're like what am i
doing here what am i doing here yep and
you the sun's rising outside and you're
like
wow this is scary i'd sleep at six wake
up at like 12 1 and do the same thing
again wake up and go back on things and
do the same thing again
tick-tock was a drug for me i'm proud
that you're not on it i can't do it
brother
i can't do it
wow that's the worst case i've ever
heard from it was terrible thing is i've
been in there bro it was terrible i've
been in there never that bad but i've
been in there but yeah oh yeah i was
going to say you were talking about your
breakfast yeah but that's what i want to
say
everybody's got boyfriends but nobody's
got girlfriends somebody's lying
bro it's actually true
netflix be like damn y'all love this
show i'ma cancel it fam
i'm so happy when they're like
ozarks it's coming back well even when
they have it or like it's official
season three of those like season four
i'm like oh thank god because every time
they finish a season
of a show that i love i'm thinking i
just know they're going to cancel yeah
yeah yeah yeah i need that reassurance
like
oh it shows last day to watch is like
december 31st i hate when i see that oh
god yeah man yeah man uh i'm gonna do
one more cool um
you guys be
you guys be 19 talking about submissive
like to who he has a twin bed [ __ ] go
to class
[Music]
and that's it that's the last one all
right man that was funny oh
guys thank you so much today thank you
that was funny man i had fun with that
one thank you very much um
i've missed the sips of that's the first
time we've done sip since we moved into
this new studio and it's and it's kicked
in and out yeah yeah yeah i'm feeling
goofy same same so guys we love you yeah
man hop on over to patreon and catch us
on thursday let's catch up and um
if not then [ __ ] off and we'll see you
on monday
i love love love all right yeah man
[Music]